Chick-fil-A produces satanic propaganda.
Yeah, you heard that right. Former owner
Dan Cathy is co-owner of Trilith
Studios, a production company that's
produced movies like The Conjuring. Does
he profess to be a Christian? Yes. In
2012, he took an open opposition against
same-sex marriage, and it caused a huge
controversy. The owners of Chick-fil-A
were a open conservative Christian
family. But now, look at the content
they're producing from this Trilith
Studios. Most of the movies they're
producing are from Marvel or Disney,
corporations that are huge on pushing
the LGBTQ plus agenda. So, what does the
name trilith actually mean? And what
does the logo represent? They answer
that question on an official Instagram
post. Why trilith? What is a trilith? By
definition, a trilith is a megalithic
monument consisting of three large
stones, two upright with a horizontal
stone resting upon them, just like
Stonehinge in the UK. For us, this
provides a nod to our roots and serves
as a metaphor for Trilith Studios,
representing our three pillars of
business, content, technology, and
facilities. Now, why on earth would a
Christian who owns a production company
use a name and logo that represents a
pagan place of ritualistic worship? A
trilith actually dates back to Baal
worship. The origin of the trilith of
Baal refers to the three enormous stone
blocks known as a trilithon that form
the foundation of the Roman temple of
Jupiter in Balebeck. The city of
Balebeck was named for the Fenosian sky
god Bale. So why would a Christian
create a film production company and
team up with people like Marvel and
Disney and make movies like The
Conjuring while using the symbol of Bale
worship to represent your company? Oh,
Trillith actually offers housing as
well. And in their healthy wellness
living center, they have a labyrinth.
The primary purpose of a labyrinth is to
provide a tool for walking meditation,
self-reflection, and spiritual journey,
allowing individuals to find clarity,
balance, and inner peace through a
single non-confusing path to the center
and back out. Labyrinths are used
globally across cultures and traditions
to reduce stress, enhance creativity,
gain insight, and connect with oneself
or a higher power through a
contemplative and symbolic physical
experience. A labyrinth is a new age
meditation practice. The closer we get
to the end of times, we're going to
start seeing more of these false
Christians being exposed and coming to
light. But it's up to us to be fruit
inspectors. Jesus said, "You'll know
them by their fruits, not because they
go to church every week or carry a Bible
or wear a cross around their neck.
You'll know them by their obedience to
the one they call Lord and Master. The
Bible says that when Christ returns,
there will be many that will say, "Lord,
Lord, didn't we do all these great
things in your name?" And he will say,
"Depart from me. I never knew you, you
workers of iniquity." As Christians, we
can't just blindly believe people and
organizations that claim to be
Christian. We have to test the spirit.
And we need to make sure that we're
right with Christ because he's coming
soon.